die rente ist sicher das betonte
arbeitsminister blüm in den 80ern immer
wieder aber ist das noch so der
präsident des arbeitgeberverbandes
gesamtmetall glaubt mittelfristig gehe
es nicht ohne mehr stunden pro woche und
mehr jahre bis zur rente
schaut man sich die demografische
entwicklung und die belastungen der
sozial- und rentenkassen an dann sind
die reserven aufgebraucht wir werden
länger und mehr arbeiten müssen
stufenweise werden wir auf das
renteneintrittsalter von 70 jahren hoch
gehen müssen auch weil das lebensalter
immer weiter steigt fakt ist das
rentensystem ist unter druck immer
weniger erwerbstätige zahlen in die
rentenkasse ein aus der ruheständler
immer länger altersgeld beziehen von
einer anhebung des rentenalters auf 70
wollen sozialverbände und gewerkschaften
dennoch nichts wissen ein klares nein
zur rente mit 70 sie ist nichts anderes
als eine rentenkürzung mit ansage für
diejenigen die in der pflege auf dem bau
oder in fabriken arbeiten ist längeres
arbeiten keine option der sozialverband
vdk sieht die lösung in einer anderen
art der finanzierung
für mich bedeutet eine solide
finanzgrundlage im rentensystem das eben
zum beispiel alle einbezogen werden dass
also die basis breite wird und eben
selbstständige beamtin beamte politiker
und politik ihren beitrag leisten in der
gesetzlichen rentenversicherung die
aussicht länger arbeiten zu müssen
jedenfalls lehnen die meisten bürger er
ab fünf jahr gehe ich in rente und noch
immer 54 traf habe ich eigentlich keine
lust habe mein partner hat er auch noch
ein bisschen älter ist und dann kommt
man hier 70er reihen und dann ist
eigentlich die möglichkeit noch was zu
tun seine freizeit sinnvoll zu gestalten
nicht mehr sehr groß wie die rente
stabil finanzieren eine der großen
zukunftsfragen die ampel koalition und
die union lehnen eine anhebung des
rentenalters derzeit ab
mit monika schnitzer mitglied im
sachverständigenrat zur begutachtung der
gesamtwirtschaftlichen entwicklung also
einer sogenannten wirtschaftsweisen mit
der kann ich jetzt sprechen über die
renten guten tag
guten tag ganz gerade gehört die ampel
verweist auf den koalitionsvertrag und
will das thema lieber nicht anfassen
auch die union winkt ab bei der rente
mit 70 machen da alle einfach die augen
zu vor dem problem
ja ich glaube das ist genau das problem
der punkt ist ja wenn man die beiträge
hört viele haben angst sie werden jetzt
direkt davon betroffen sein aber es geht
ja darum dass man das für die zukunft
sichert das heißt es geht jetzt um
entscheidungen die man treffen will die
männer aus die generationen in zehn
zwanzig jahren betreffen wird und da ist
es einfach wichtig jetzt schon klartext
zu reden denn so in der aktuellen form
wenn wir alles so lassen wie es ist sie
mir tatsächlich schnell an die grenzen
gekommen sie gehöre ja als
wirtschaftsweiser eigentlich zum
beratergremium die erklären sie sich
dass dann die politik offensichtlich
trotzdem nicht auf sie hört wenn das
problem jetzt schon sichtbar ist
naja das ist kein thema mit dem man
wähler gewinnt das hat man ja in dem
beitrag auch gesehen trotzdem muss man
glücklich ehrlich darüber reden wir sind
aktuell in einer situation wo drei
beitragszahler einen rentner finanzieren
die 15 die anderen es nur noch zwei
topfahrer sein
geben momentan 100 milliarden aus dem
haushalt aus dem bundeshaushalt jährlich
in die rentenkasse rhein und die zu
unterstützen das ist schon ein gutes
viertel das haushalts dem 25 jahren wird
die hälfte sein alles wenn wir nichts
tun aber an der stelle muss man auch
sagen renteneintrittsalter ist ja nicht
die einzige stellschraube über die man
reden kann man kann auch über die
beitragssätze sprechen man kann auch die
renten zu wechsel sprechen alles sind
die margen sind also stellschrauben an
denen man etwas drehen kann um das für
die menschen auch in zukunft
tragbar zu halten die drei
stellschrauben haben sie angesprochen
also renteneintrittsalter ist das eine
beitragshöhe oder rentenhöhe das andere
an welcher denn sie haben jetzt alle
schon drei genannt müssen wir dann als
erste schrauben wird es so sein dass
alle drei im grunde geschraubt werden
müssen sozusagen die rentenhöhe und
nicht nur das eintrittsalter und auch
die beitragshöhe
ja ich glaube man muss wirklich an allen
drei schrauben drehen denn sonst wird
jeder einzelne schraube zu sehr
ausgereizt und was uns nämlich das thema
beitragssätze an der stelle ansprechen
wenn man jetzt die beitragssätze schon
allmählich anheben wird erhält man den
großen vorteil dass die aktuelle
generation der baby-boomer dir dann bald
in rente gehen wir doch noch für ein
paar jahre etwas dazu beitragen würde
zum renten sie sehen zur finanzierung
des rentensystems und das ist deswegen
eigentlich auch besonders gerechtfertigt
weil die aktuelle baby boomer generation
einfach zu wenig kinder bekommen hat um
den generationenvertrag zu erfüllen
generationenvertrag bedeutet ja die
jungen arbeiten für die alten aber sie
müssen eben auch dafür sorgen dass sie
dass es selbst wieder denn junge gibt
wenn sie die alten sind und das hat die
aktuelle baby boomer generation
versorgen jetzt ist natürlich die frage
das sind alles sachen die passieren
müssen sie dann selbst gesagt dass alles
ist unpopulär also wie viel zeit bleibt
wann muss man da dran
ich denke wir müssen einfach jetzt eine
ehrliche debatte darüber führen und dann
klar machen und das ist mir auch ganz
wichtig an der stelle das zu betonen
klar machen dass das natürlich nicht
bedeutet dass alle die jetzt kurz vor
der rente stehen dann tatsächlich länger
arbeiten denn für die ist das
renteneintrittsalter ja schon angehoben
worden auf dann am ende 67 es geht jetzt
darum dass die generationen die in zehn
15 20 jahren rente gehen dass
dienstleister dass sie etwas länger
arbeiten müssen und man muss natürlich
an der stelle auch ganz klar darüber
diskutieren dass es nicht jeder
gleichermaßen
leisten kann dh dass manche berufe die
körperlich sehr stark belastet sind
natürlich nicht bis 70 in dem gleichen
beruf tätig sein können das heißt man
muss sehr frühzeitig darüber nachdenken
wie schaffen wir es hier zu
differenzieren beziehungsweise auch
dafür zu sorgen dass menschen und
schulen können wenn sie in berufen tätig
sind die man ja tatsächlich
ehrlicherweise nicht ge 70 ausüben kann
sagte die wirtschaftsweise und
wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin von der
universität münchen monika schnitzer
vielen dank für ihre zeit ich danke
ihnen